good afternoon how're you guys doing
good
gets a little sleepy after lunch maybe
but it's been a pretty good conference
so far I've seen some pretty good
sessions thank you guys for coming and
being willing to look at a subject
matter that has evaded me for quite some
time but once I started figuring it out
I figured I really wish I had a session
at a conference it's just like told us
to me and at about an hour saved me time
and all the effort so this is a my love
letter do you guys that I decided to
just put all my research in a deck and
go through the things I have learned
this is absolutely open to questions if
you'd like but as we go you might find
some answers so try to hold them for the
end sound good awesome
all right let's start out with the way
that I usually introduce myself saying
usually is how I do it now okay em hello
my name is Heather downing I do lots of
things and stuff Koby you can see by how
nicely everything is laid out that I
have a a professional photograph that
was taken like 10 years ago and lots of
details about what it is I have I do
right but really when people think about
me it isn't in such detail it's usually
done very concisely very simply because
humans don't think about all those
details when they think about a person
what comes to mind usually are things
like the Hollett person is innovative
that person I associate with enterprise
space like something with big companies
right enterprise I associate them with
some sort of consumer facing role and I
associate them maybe with I don't know
if this would work there we go
that this person is pleaseplease did you
do a speaker I've done this before and
those are a lot more singular but yet
when we write a resume and when we put
our LinkedIn together it is exhausting
to read your all stuff it just really is
because human beings are
computers we make them to look after the
things that we don't want to remember
okay so when we communicate digitally
verbally see how concise and simply you
can go so now that we have that
introduction isn't that a lot easier to
remember a lot easier make things simple
but the real question is what are you
wanting out of your career like what do
you really want research confirms that
there's a real disconnect between your
performance and your job outcome very
huge disconnect you could be the
hardest-working developer out there and
nobody notices you this was me I know
it's funny I look funny normally it
would be a situation where people are
like notice me only because of the weird
hair colors I have or what I'm wearing
that doesn't quite fit in but that's not
the right kind of noticing like I
usually just said yeah thanks for not
you know crashing that app thanks for
not doing that but that's pretty much
the interaction that I got and I really
wanted to know why other people who are
getting promoted before me now there's a
lot of factors that go into this but
this is also something that a lot of my
really good talented friends we're also
facing so while you could say uh-oh is
because of this or that reason and you
can justify it any way you want I didn't
want to feel helpless right if you're
too busy keeping your head down and your
nose to the grindstone it's harder to
see you part of managing yourself and
your trajectory means you have to make
it easier for people to find
opportunities for you okay if you get
coy or bashful about your
accomplishments it does both yourself
and your work a huge disservice okay it
may unintentionally make the job of
managing you even harder ironically
which is interesting because I was
raised that we just never talked about
ourselves we don't talk about things
we've done we don't want to come across
as prideful or bragging
but the reality is while we always need
more developers there's still a lot of
developers there's a lot how do you
stand out right this was a really big
question I had early on that guy you see
getting promoted that was a total idiot
in your brain that's because he's doing
shameless self-promotion all the time
all the time he's never out of sight
never out of mind so you should do the
same thing only there's much more
refined way of being in somebody's mind
okay you don't need to lose self-respect
in the process you need to put on a
clown suit but you have to realize that
your voice is important in this scent
does not mean received is quite a
profound thing half of your job is doing
your work and the other half of your job
is communicating that it's been done
right because if you do it and I don't
hear about it do I know what's going on
not really not really so when you do
things tell people about it I just look
at this as a simple transaction I am a
vocal log of the things I have done okay
we miss out when we wrongly assume that
other people will know about your work
and all of our great work without having
to tell them it'll just be obvious all
right because believing that pointing to
your achievements is being overly
self-promotional and that good work
should be enough on its own is
ironically very selfish because you must
think it's all about you if people are
just gonna not notice all the time okay
you are almost always on your mind but
that goes for everyone else too okay
most everyone is busy with their own
concerns and their plans and their
problems and their lives there's too
much going on even when I went into the
mall that's adjacent to this hotel the
other day there was so many options that
as I was just looking for the one thing
I was looking forward
a hair curling iron I actually forgot
how much the prices were of the ones I
just passed the ones I just saw right
then because there were so many of them
so when you are a manager or somebody
that has a powerful role you deal with
so many people and so many situations at
the same time you cannot really recall
unless it was a very powerful memory and
so somebody would argue with me saying
well as long as what you're doing that
is great work it's a powerful memory
you shouldn't have to say anything okay
sure but never assume the air manager
has a good memory I certainly don't have
a very small cache in the side of this
head very small so try to do them a
favor and tell them there are some
habits of developers I've noticed that
are well-known in the industry that are
always in their mind the good news is
that becoming a super employee is not
some sort of rarefied secret if a
combination of skill set in mindset okay
you can begin to develop that for
yourself by focusing on some key habits
okay and because I like to create new
neural pathways in my brain that will
just subconsciously do these things for
me I decided to put them in a deck for
you the first one is to pay attention to
it other people value super employees
are always studying the Preferences and
the goals of their direct supervisors
their supervisors supervisors and the
company at large they actually take
interest in what the heck the company
does okay they're doing things above and
beyond what other employees are doing
and they're showing interest in it
they're motivated in showing that they
want to learn what it's like to be at
the top and in the front okay the
results of paying attention is being
able to discern what needs to be done
and take action on it without being
asked that's when you become really
valuable because remember there's the
manager and the director just trying to
keep all the ducks in the row if you can
like assist with some of those Ducks
being in row the relief of that is very
noticeable
and you can do that at any level pay an
intention to more than just what your
job is great another habit I noticed is
that they choose the right place for
their talents it's really hard to be a
super employee if the company's needs
are very different from your abilities I
went through this many times I'm like
well I just really want to make a good
salary and that's totally fair by the
way you're allowed to have that being
the number one priority but if my talent
lied and my proof of concept innovation
work but I worked for a legacy
application company maybe that would not
be something that would make me want to
get up in the morning okay
so I found that over time my motivation
was just kind of wane and that's
definitely not going to make you be
noticed right a 2015 report by the
Cicero group in the USA found that one
of the most important factors in
employees consistently producing great
work was recognition big surprise 37% of
the responders said that being
recognized by a manager or by the
company was the most important factor in
the happiness and therefore the driver
in the great work that was produced so
choosing where to work is very important
they also focus on the big picture
thinking now this is starting to sound
exhausting right but I'm assuming since
all of you are here with me instead of
going to a technical talk which I'm
giving by the way a little bit later
that you're interested in being noticed
and then being heads above the rest
right otherwise why would you give me
your time so we're just gonna cross that
off the list and assume you're all
motivated right you're all motivated
exceptional performers are able to
maintain dual focus on the task at hand
as well as how it fits into the bigger
picture if they don't understand
something they get the information they
need to make its importance clear
in addition they also are able to better
prioritize so that their activities and
energy are focused where they are the
most value to the company this is where
it got really tough for me because I
wasn't exactly sure if I had permission
to do that kind of thing like if it
isn't my role I mean am I allowed to be
in board meetings am I allowed to know
about this I'm not talking about going
outside of your reporting structure but
you could definitely be helpful you can
always be right on the fringe and be
asking lots of questions one of my
favorite things to do is in my
one-on-one with my manager is to ask
what can I do to help us get more work
in the company because I notice it's
slow right now or is there any way I
could maybe go out on a sales call and
that sounds kind of strange but having a
technical person on a sales call it's
actually very helpful and while you
might not be the role just say I'd like
to be a fly on the wall so I can
understand you know how to prioritize my
work and maybe you might have someone
dictate work on this ticket today ok we
work on this other one tomorrow whenever
you're done with it that's great but
that's your opportunity to say sure but
hey I know that this one piece is
actually a little bit more important to
our clients so I'm gonna do that first
to make sure that we've got it in the
bag all that's doing right there in just
one sentence they could say yes or no it
shows them you actually care about the
bottom line for the company okay that
gets noticed they're also comfortable
with being uncomfortable this is
probably one of my best lessons over the
past year you have to be working on
things that are difficult for you
difficult not fun difficult because even
if you are completely distraction free
and getting a lot of coding hours in if
you're just building the same app over
and over again that's not necessarily
stretching you to the boundaries of your
skills and you cannot blame your company
for that that's up to you and because
you guys are all here you get
ten points to Gryffindor for being here
to learn new skills right very very cool
but if you remember if you're not
deliberately stretching yourself you may
not be trying to structure skills in the
direction that will actually help you
grow as a technical contributor that was
the biggest differentiator that I
noticed in my everyday job was anybody
who took the time independently to
educate themselves on something and then
share it Sharon gives you two things
Sharon allows you to regurgitate what
you've learned and therefore strengthen
it because you had to teach someone else
it also allows you to be visible in your
external growth because even if you're
not working on anything related to AI if
you read something about it and you want
to just talk about it on a lunch break
or whatever you want to do it
demonstrates that you care and you are a
top performer so there is no downside to
doing this kind of a thing and they like
their colleagues this was hard for me
okay I am very happy to be here and I
genuinely care about all people now but
that was not the case in the beginning
okay definitely had a hard time with
this not everybody likes me kind of
high-energy I'm kind of weird so a lot
of the quieter developers really just
didn't want to be in a room with me and
that's that's fair and I just kind of
started resenting them for not being
more open but high performers are in
tune with the people around them and
they can sense when they need something
or don't need that they possess they
possess soft skills like empathy which
is learnable by the way you're not born
with it you get to learn it and you're
able to relate well to other people
because you take the time and the effort
to understand them all of them yes even
the jerk that you take the time to
understand why do they do what they do
you know how we debug code you can debug
people why is this not working
misconnections can because she's just
not working I guess they just hate me
because of this or don't like me because
of that or
I just don't like this guy cuz he's
annoying yes that is a symptom of the
problem be a detective be people
detective a high performer will put the
human first and seek the connection and
only then can there be trust and this
becomes really really important down the
line all of those full rooms that you
see at really large conferences like
keynote opening and people have a lot of
trust and respect in the industry
because they also sought a connection
outside of just their technical
abilities there's a great quote by simon
Sinek is that empathy is being concerned
about the human and not just their
output which is very difficult if you
chose a career to not be you know in
front of the house in a hotel you know
talking to people you wanted to just be
you in the computer it can be difficult
but this is very important because what
do you guys all want to be you want to
be visible you wanna be noticed you want
to be considered a top performer this is
just an additional skill that will
become more and more important as you
rise every person needs to be seen
understood and validated all of us need
it you can dismiss someone who disagrees
with you or you could try to figure out
why they say what they say and why they
do what they do this was so difficult
for me but slowly I started getting the
hang of it high performers also pay
attention to it other people value I
think we talked about that before right
these developers are studying the
preferences and goals of their direct
supervisors and going to bub and Beyond
so when do you have time to do your own
work seems like this is a whole other
second job just to keep growing but you
can actually work this into things day
by day you need to think about how to
become a trusted voice so this there's
two pieces to this I don't have to tell
you that you have to kind of know a
little bit I don't see everything a
little bit about what you're doing so if
you talk about like for instance I'd
a heck of a lot about security but I
probably could go up here and say you
shouldn't use repeated passwords on the
Internet
you should trust me right well that's
pretty much common knowledge so I'm not
gonna be a trusted voice on that subject
the way that maybe one of the other
security advisors would so I kind of got
a look at it a little bit more again you
don't have to be the expert but you have
to demonstrate that you actually put
enough time into getting your answer and
you have a reason for why you would
grabbed it and I know that this all
seems like it's obvious to some of you
but it wasn't to me I don't people
naturally so I've had to learn how to do
this it was really hard for me because I
felt like I was acting you know it felt
like I was on some sort of television
show and I had to pretend to like
everybody you don't have to be a smooth
ER you know just
engage and be positive and respectful
this is also hard for me because I'm
very sarcastic and I come from a long
line of people who love to complain so I
had to alter in my brain my personality
in order to do this I want to do that oh
people should just accept me for me darn
it but the reality is life is exhausting
don't exhaust people more with your
attitude okay it's musing though is a
turn-off instead you have to demonstrate
leadership and also positively and never
negatively engage with your peers and
colleagues outside of your small group
okay you can be critical as needed but
you always have to be positive I know
you probably get a little sleep last
night or you're really frustrated about
a subject but you have to put a positive
spin on the way you present something or
people are not gonna take it okay
naked criticism will get you worse than
nowhere it'll get you in the cellar okay
your peers feedback even if it's just
informal and word of mouth it's critical
to your promotion there is a really good
chart that kind of indicates the growth
of this kind of exchange it's kind of
try
this kind of connection for lack of a
better term okay we're gonna look at the
way that this is set up has anybody seen
this matrix before a couple of you good
all right
most of you never seen this awesome I'm
your first introduction there's an
excellent book called radical candor
that all of you should read we're gonna
start with the first one
obnoxious aggression think about all the
trolls on Stack Overflow okay yeah mmm
if you do this for them then you have to
be willing to encourage them to do this
for you right
that's what radical candor is
unfortunately the trolls online maybe
right in their statement like yes you
know why would you why that isn't really
the question you're asking what you
really need to figure out is how to be a
developer and then come back and ask
your question like that is then one of
the most common responses I read and I'm
Michael that's not helpful is anybody
even if they're right even if they're
right maybe this person does need a
little bit more you can't be obnoxiously
aggressive to someone that doesn't trust
you doesn't know you has no rapport with
you it doesn't work you just look like a
jerk even if you're the right jerk and
no one wants to work with you that's not
how you rise it as hot and the next one
over here is manipulative in sincerity
okay
this is really tough for me okay
this is where you get a lot of the
passive-aggressive
oh yeah we're totally doing this for you
yeah we totally care about you you know
we're just gonna we're just gonna
document this you know just just just to
have it on file you know that's that's
that manipulative in sincerity okay
we're just manipulating your emotions to
try to get you out the door and that's
not how you build trust the other one is
kind of interesting to me ruinous
empathy has anybody here watched friends
like the television show ever before
there is a famous episode
in which one of the characters takes up
playing the piano and singing okay and
one of their roommates wants to be
supportive
but so really goes all out and say oh
you sound amazing that was amazing that
was incredible and so the character that
was playing who's clearly not amazing
and was quite off-key was like really
that's great
signed up for an entire performance in
front of a huge audience and then ended
up getting very embarrassed by the whole
situation because people boo them
offstage right if you don't want to be
that you don't want to not be truthful
there is such a thing as too nice you
know like I used to say oh my mom will
always tell me that I look good you know
so don't ask your mom if you look good
right as you know that they're always
gonna say yes but this is probably the
most mild of all of the egregious ones
in order to achieve radical candor you
have to care enough about the person to
challenge them directly so that they
know that you don't mean them any harm
you mean them help I was told actually
early this morning by someone I trusted
that I knew cared about me that you know
brought something to my attention that
says I'm not trying to hurt your
feelings but X because I knew they were
trying to help the outcome okay but they
only had permission to be that direct
because we established a relationship
first this is really tough for any of
you who has direct reports are there
anybody here who manages people in the
room maybe a couple of you cool so I'm
at it imagine though that the the power
was inverted you don't have any power
you brought as the power how do you deal
with that right you have to go out of
your way to figure out what they like
what makes them tick and not be a
schmoozer just figure out when they have
a good day when they seem to be in a
good mood why is that you know and then
over time just demonstrate that you paid
attention that you care about them as a
person not as your
manager but as a person and that's
difficult because maybe I just really
don't care about that person this is
interesting to me because when I think
about the fact that someone doesn't like
me
or vice versa it's usually because we
haven't taken enough time to figure out
how to communicate and if you don't work
on this you're gonna have a really hard
time as an employee yes it's really
tough when you have to manage up but
that's sometimes what you gotta do
another thing you need to do is truly
open your connection right does anybody
know what the strongest communication
style is anybody have any guesses hmm no
speaking is only seven percent effective
words seven percent effective your vocal
tone like the way that I'm speaking is
38% effective but the most effective is
your body language okay so if you talk
to somebody and you're like this you
look relaxed you also look closed off
right especially if you talk to them
while you're typing this is a bad habit
of mine talk to you then while you're
typing and you're not actually looking
at them even though you're being
cheerful and everything like that you
are demonstrating to them that whatever
they're saying to you is not that
important that you would actually have
to look up and look at them when you're
speaking okay so that subconsciously
sends the message that you kind of
bother me I'm kind of busy but I'll talk
to you because you're my boss okay I
know it's annoying because every time we
take a break from the screen we have to
reset our context and it takes us a
little bit to ramp up but it's important
to stop look at the person
another trick I've learned is to get
down on the level or up on their level
don't be sitting down when they're
standing up stand up to meet them if
they're sitting down and sit down with
them try to be at the same level because
it shows that you're attempting to care
so I just came back from this weekend
going to New Zealand
not nearly as vast as this country but
it was interesting to me to be able to
experience a little bit of the
indigenous culture there and how to
different tribes would like meet up and
try to figure out if they're Friend or
Foe
and it was like this huge ordeal it was
all the stuff and it was a really big
deal like the way in which they they met
each other and the concept of like
touchy noses and and the sight of your
shoulder and breathing together and then
sure you can come in and have dinner
with us I'm like why is that important
even though I didn't understand any of
the words it was very obvious what was
happening from their body language as
primitive as that is we think we're
really advanced but we're pretty
primitive beings after all okay I can
watch entire shows in Spanish which I
don't know the hoot of and tried it and
kind of figure out what is happening in
the drama okay it's pretty fascinating
so pay attention just be aware of what
you're doing with your body and how open
that you're being okay you can make this
a habit there's a wonderful story that I
was told just last year about the
concept of learning empathy so one of my
friends was convinced that you're either
born just loving the world we're not you
find it scary we find it annoying or
frustrating and I would argue we're
already born crying so we're probably
all frustrated right away so how do you
create this habit children learn habits
based on what their parents are doing or
where their caretakers are doing right
so we're all sitting on a plane was the
way the story goes and sure enough right
after takeoff
you got the shrill sound of a baby
scream yay this is why I have nice
noise-canceling headphones but everybody
was reacting differently to that my
reaction was I would like to sleep on
this flight turn on noise canceling
right that's my reaction is that's
annoying
I want to block it out some other
responses that people could be seen on
their face was sympathy for the parent
of the child who had to try to calm the
child down who's clearly in pain from
the ears getting all stuffed up right as
they're ascending and other people were
so annoyed by it that they would
physically get up and like walk away and
try to go to another seat so there was
all these different reactions right and
then there was a little four-year-old
boy who kind of wiggled out of his seat
and walked down the aisle to where the
little baby was and dug through his
little backpack and handed the baby his
little pacifier because he figured well
whenever I cry this makes me feel better
here we go that was his reaction and
that young you can be taught empathy
right so I was told once that children
are selfish they don't really care but
anybody but themselves cuz they don't
know how to do that but it can be taught
very very young it was interesting that
that was the only one on the entire
plane that actually felt like well
they're clearly suffering maybe I can do
something about it and well this might
sound like a story about just being a
good person it's not it's about the fact
that he had to experience empathy to
know what to do about the situation so
when you don't know what to do with your
manager or your peer you have to find
some way to empathize with them to know
what to do you have to be able to
experience a little bit through their
eyes and through their shoes and that's
hard for me I don't have any kids so
that's a little difficult right but I am
an aunt of many many many kids okay so
when I do talk to my sisters I try to
ask them a little bit more about it so
that I can relate to my peers who do
have kids to go pick up at three or four
in the afternoon and they can't stay and
deploy and I need to stay and deploy
something for them you know I have to
think about what they would be going
through even though I didn't personally
go through because once you learn why
someone is behaving the way they are
then you can generate that empathy
if they feel hurt and that you belong
you've met them on their terms that
fosters a feeling of safety for that
person regardless of the power
difference by the way your manager has
to kind of feel safe with you I know
that sounds weird but have you been a
manager before I can tell you that
they're employees that I felt like I
could just be candid with because I knew
that we had an understanding right I
could be a human being with them and not
their manager because I felt safe with
them you can control that and vice versa
if you're a manager you've got in in a
way that power is not really a good
thing to have because then people feel
automatically obligated to just tell you
whatever you want to hear you need to
take an active interest in who they are
and what they do okay because with
safety comes trust all right and with
trust comes the ability to have radical
candor with one another with open
communication brings ability and with
the social ability plus your technical
ability then you can reform in a way
that is habitually going to make you
stand out you progressively become
better and better at understanding that
empathy and once you have this feedback
loop in place what you can build
together successfully is the force
multiplier that can make or break your
career that's kind of what I decided to
call it it was like a force multiplier
loop this is a while loop yes and this
works because once you've got this loop
in place and they just kind of got it
automatically going you can like 10x
your career you can 10x your happiness
all these things and you can have a huge
amount of impact to multiply that impact
because people will forget what you said
and they forget what you did but
never forget how you made them feel
never and I'm sure all of you remembers
that one manager or that one developer
you worked with with that was great but
a jerk you always remember that you also
remember the one that you loved to work
with another role that you can take on
to getting noticed is to externalize
thought leadership this right here what
I'm doing right now is an example of
externalizing thought leadership I'm
speaking outside of my job this has
nothing to do with my job and I'm
demonstrating that I'm a thought leader
in this space you can do this at a user
group you can do this anywhere it could
be as small as a couple of groups of
people at high school or it could just
be across the internet she doesn't have
to be in person but externalizing this
the thoughts that you have in place and
the opinions that you have is incredibly
important and to be able to stand out
you know why because a lot of people
don't do it there's a lot of people who
are intelligent and smart like I have a
really bad time doing a blog I'm just
not a blogger but I'm a youtuber so it's
a different way of externalizing the
thought leadership but it's very
effective so I recognize that I'm just
not a writer I don't like writing it's
not it's not my thing I could get better
at it if I decided to really focus on it
but I have also discovered I can be just
as effective if not more in a different
type of media okay which by the way if
you're interested it's called the hello
world show it's on YouTube check it out
this was really hard for me to learn
working hard and doing a good job is
just not enough
promotion and big companies of any scale
it's about leadership and in many cases
management because you're gonna get paid
really well if you work hard and do a
good job you know you just won't get
promoted and go all that far you'll get
well paid but you won't get recognized
you have to lead by example outside of
your company also demonstrates ability
this is really key by the way if you are
not feeling like you're getting
opportunities at your job
talk up present things externally and
then tell your manager about it tell
your company about it usually it makes
them look good though they've got
somebody demonstrating that who they
have working for them is intelligent
enough and as much of a leader that they
want to share knowledge okay
this is a great way of getting noticed
at one of the jobs I've had before the
saying was you don't get promoted you
leave the building
knock on the outside and change your
suit and I thought that was such a odd
freeze but then I kind of get what
they're talking about in order to really
get noticed as somebody who could take
the company in a different way you had
to be different you had to show them
that outside of your normal job now that
isn't always the case
but if you don't feel like your
situation is fair make it fair make it
fair for you sharing your knowledge just
places outside of your work can put you
on the fast track and the big one why
you should network so it's awesome that
you're here and you're learning
something but the most important track
that you'll have at this conference is
the hallway track so as you're walking
around in between sessions and tonight
at the attendee party make a point in
meeting different people it's
uncomfortable it's weird but luckily for
us we're all at a tech conference so it
kind of goes without saying that we all
know that we're a little strange right
it's totally fine say hello you have no
idea who you're gonna talk to I said
hello to somebody once at a conference
last year
turns out they worked for one of the big
five on one of my favorite platforms and
I got an opportunity to kind of build a
little proof of concept for them and it
got published pretty cool and that was
just from a hallway conversation oh yeah
I like to do this stuff and otherwise
how would they have found me
happenstance you have to kind of make
the odds in your favor having a large
and valuable Network is a fantastic
asset for advancing your career and your
life in general even if things aren't
gonna work
this current company that is a wonderful
way to not panic if layoffs start
happening or you realize that the
current job is just not for you you are
going to rely on your network to not
just be someone to speak for you but to
also find opportunities that can be a
direct link instead of you going through
you know the two to three months back
and forth as a recruiter and eventually
getting an opportunity to get in front
of a manager it's a great way to do it
is probably one of the most valuable
things you will ever ever learn in your
tech career is how important networking
is and it doesn't mean what do you think
it means so when most programmers ask me
about networking what they're really
asking me about is how they can use
people to get what they want okay I'm
not about that at all in fact my
personal philosophy and the one I firmly
believe you have to have to have true
success is to figure out how you can
give as many people as possible what
they want or even better what they need
and think about it first there's a book
I believe it's called like how to win
friends and influence people I haven't
read all of it but I understand that
this saying is an excerpt from is that
if you want to have a connection with
somebody who's very well-connected then
you have to do something for them first
without them even asking
or better yet ask them if they wouldn't
mind helping you out with some small
favor and then suddenly you feel like
you have a connection because if it's an
easy thing to fulfill and I said sure no
problem
now you actually have something you can
talk about for at least five minutes
right it's so interesting the more that
I get involved
with deep technical knowledge the more I
become fascinated by the human condition
because so much of our world still
revolves around human decision-making
conscious and subconscious let's think
about the wrong way to network most
software developers only start worrying
about networking or trying to network at
all when they need something and it's
usually a new
you job right but that is the absolute
worst time and the wrong way to build a
network building the network takes time
trying to rush the process and do it
quickly means you probably reek of
desperation and coming off as a sleazy
moocher so just trying to be nice to
people so you can extract something from
them we are pretty intelligent and we
have good intuition about that kind of a
thing let's talk about the right way to
network shall we the right approach to
building a network is building
relationships and just like romantic
relationships real business and
professional relationships cannot be
rushed imagine if you met a person you'd
like to pursue a romantic relationship
with and on the first date you asked
them to marry you I mean it has happened
not to me but I it has happened right
that probably wouldn't go over too well
you know and yet many software
developers want to approach a networking
and exactly that manner think about the
long game if you need like if you need
something right now there is a role for
that it's called a recruiter and they
understand that it's just temporary for
this time you're building that
relationship it's not really a good
relationship it's just a fast
relationship right but the ones that
make the biggest difference in your
career are the ones that you play for
the long game also network in person I
know it's difficult especially if
there's not a lot going on around your
area so where do you actually go to
network everywhere you should always be
networking we are lucky enough to be in
an industry that every other industry
needs in order to work even agriculture
usually has some sort of IT component so
you probably can even talk to people in
that industry once you run into on the
street you'd be surprised how many
people I just happen to chat with while
I'm in line for a coffee because you
guys don't like Starbucks here so a
coffee somewhere right and just started
asking what do you do what are you here
for and it turns out oh yeah there's the
that's a we automate this or automate
that I mean I don't work on that
some smart IT people do but that's cool
and then all of a sudden they remember
you as that IT person so when they said
I need one maybe they'll call you and
those aren't people that are in our
industry exactly but they do have need
for us the easiest and best thing to do
in this case is to find groups of people
who are interested in what you're
interested in which is why you're here
right
meetups are great I use meetup comm all
the time be willing to put in the time
for that and go to software development
conference so you guys already have a
huge take off your box right there even
though it's sometimes expensive to come
here it's also great places to meet new
quality people and to pick up some
training at the same time because the
point is everybody at this conference is
invested if it was a free conference not
as much investment okay whether you paid
for your company paid for it regardless
there's intrinsic value and the kinds of
people that walk through the doors okay
when you're here walk around and talk to
people and attend different sessions
it's really important that you put
yourself out there well you may not be
up here you need to still connect down
there and of course the big one yes
branding and social media I've worked
for a company that does advertising okay
I've learned this firsthand that if you
don't put yourself out there nobody
knows you exist it's important to do it
however I don't really like
participating in it a lot and having it
be in the front of mind so I oughta mate
a lot of it you can use HootSuite or
other kinds of things for Twitter where
you can just you know if you're up late
at night you can just kind of write a
whole bunch of different tweets you're
thinking about maybe something about
architecture or maybe something that you
think is cool on TV whatever you want to
say and make sure that you know you load
them up and then it will at time to
intervals release them so you don't have
to remember oh I haven't tweeted today
ah now I'm out of sight and out of mind
you can just trick the system and just
preload them right it's awesome it's
awesome
you can hire somebody to do this for you
but honestly with just a little bit of
practice it's pretty easy to do it
yourself
also don't forget that corporate sites I
have a different audience so when I say
corporate sites I'm thinking
specifically of like LinkedIn right
that's much more about the formal
position of that you hold so you could
have maybe tailored different kinds of
comments and responses based on your
platform it's not too terrible I mean we
have all sorts of levels of abstraction
for our software architecture it's not
too different from social media and you
got to be really honest with yourself
about who you are
when it comes to creating an authentic
personal brand that means you have to
share the good the bad and the real with
your followers aspirational is great but
being relatable is what creates
connections for example if for any of
you who paid attention
I've been reading my notes as I go
because I have a awful memory and it's
okay that I said that to you because
it's relatable because lots of people
forget stuff and it's well I might feel
and I did for many years that's a
detriment and people think less of me
for it that's actually not the case
that's not something that I can help but
I can put you know things in place to
make me effective regardless and being
open about the habits I put in place
actually does create that connection it
absolutely does even one of one of the
really big hire at people Microsoft that
I follow even recently said that oh I
thought that they weren't all that
special or that important but then
somebody said oh wow you got up and you
did a talk and you weren't feeling well
and it was obvious that you know you had
to you know check your your blood sugar
levels like right on stage and that
actually really affected me because I
realized that you know my kid who is
coming up in the world I was worried
about whether or not they could have a
career in the things they loved but here
you were demonstrating that you still
like gave your talk and still talked
about all this and clearly it's possible
even though he at the time felt like
gosh this is so embarrassing that I'm
here I'm on the stage and I have to like
- sure blood sugar levels because I'm a
diabetic right but really it actually
was even more impactful in a good way
now there is a caveat to this though
okay you can be relatable by being a
bully that's not the right way to go I'm
not saying that because I want you all
to be Mary Poppins and lovely okay be
yourself don't be a jerk don't be a jerk
on social media it will haunt you
forever don't do it if you have all
these problems and thoughts make sure
they can talk to someone about it just
don't talk about it on the Internet okay
it's a pretty decent guideline that lots
of people don't follow so try to be
someone who follows in I promise it'll
be a lot better for you in the long run
so you got a post with purpose don't
just spam a bunch of things it's really
cool when somebody shares pieces of real
thought processes and you can tell right
away whether or not they were just some
headlines that they snagged and then
retweeted or was something genuinely
from them you have to avoid all that
filler content I used to stress out if I
didn't share with my online audience
every day okay every day so I would
search for something anything to keep
the engagement going and put me in front
of people's faces it's exhausting like
Here I am you know doing an extra time
trying to further my skills outside of
the job that already is more than 40
hours a week and now I'm trying to also
become my own salesperson and I was I
mean was just a lot filler content
though wasn't giving my audience the
best of me and it didn't come off as
authentic or genuine it came off as
filler and it came off as fake so now
before I post anything online I asked
myself what purpose does this serve how
am I actually connecting to anybody does
this even contribute to my personal
brand I didn't even really like that
phrase like what is personal branding
what does that even mean I feel like it
like I made my own logo and stamped it
on my forehead you know so weird but
it's true when people think of you what
do they think you can control that I
know it seems like you can't but
promise you you can even large companies
right now are proving that as long as
they show a genuine side of them things
will work out all right
I even think last week like a shoe
company just kind of put out what they
believed it was controversial but in the
end people still respected the fact that
they were willing to get behind whatever
they they said right and their stock
ended up going up because they were that
was genuinely a position that they felt
it was a risk but it totally paid off
and speak like a human being
my advice for developing your tone is
simple and don't overthink it I speak to
my audience the way I would speak to a
friend or if you were in my living room
they were having a cup of tea this is
exactly the same way I talk if you come
and see me tonight at the attendee party
it'll be exactly the same
I'm informal and I'm upbeat you want
people to relate to you and feel like
they know you it helps to develop that
trust especially when they're not in
front of you okay it's better when you
do have something to promote once they
have almost like that off line candor
that way your readers don't feel like
they're being fed such an ad such an
advertisement but rather an exchange of
information between friends even though
clearly don't know each other very well
if you speak to them as if they're
already welcomed in your circle you know
that whole you're already welcomed and
the tribe and you're already welcomed to
dinner if you speak to people like that
they instantly relax and there is an
unspoken trust that starts getting
generated I'm sure you know I'm talking
about like when a speaker walks on stage
at a TED talk and they say the first
five or six words that comes out of your
mouth you know whether or not you're
gonna like him is it delivery is it just
you know I don't know is it is it a is
it the way that they look
is it the tone of voice the answer is
yes all of the above is the way that
they delivered something because they
thought about how do they want to make
you feel you can be a really effective
speaker and walk out here and say
something that jar is everybody right
away it's really effective for people
who are trying to t
someone a lesson or you know really
bring a lot of attention to like crime
or violence or something like that but
in general you want to be inviting when
you speak to people be and be moderately
responsive so social media has the word
social in it for a reason it's in order
to grow your personal brand you need to
nurture your community and respect your
readers the same way create
conversations and answer questions and
encourage the discussion I mean Stack
Overflow is a great forum for this due
to the searchable nature of that you
don't need to engage every second of
every day just do it with a small amount
of consistency so you don't miss
engaging opportunities of course if
you're on vacation you're on vacation
but just try to reach out habitually it
becomes easier over time and you can do
it in smaller and smaller windows
because remember if you aren't online
you are out of sight whether that is a
placeholder like profile or you actually
actively having a conversation back and
forth you're out of sight and this whole
purpose is right to be visible use it to
your advantage you could be the best
developer in the world without someone
taking you notice the opportunities to
advance will not come they won't come
why leave that in the hands of someone
else to do the work for you if you're
lucky someone really cares it's like hey
you should give this person to promotion
but that's not normally what happens
that's not that it never happens but it
doesn't normally happen take control of
at least having a crafted image so when
people search for you they get a sense
of what it would be like to work with
you and I mean I post on social media
knowing that I work at a company that
can read it right so I keep that in mind
that I'm also kind of exercising this is
who I could be if you just gave me that
promotion so you look at all look at all
this wealth of information that I'm
putting out there look at all this
external thought leadership right that
is your permission to stretch your wings
a little bit without being demanding
directly at your job it matters so what
is
attitude matter I mean I believe skills
can be taught
I believe empathy can be taught I don't
think attitude can be taught if you care
I can teach you if you don't care I can
teach you so attitude does matter almost
one of the first things that most
managers think about is whether or not
they can tolerate you in that new role
it's like well if I give this person
power is that a good thing you know is a
good idea to have power I travel a lot
all over the world and I often times
will compare and contrast the
differences going through border
crossings and customs and security with
all of the different countries I
personally think that some of the
friendliest people I've ever met in my
life
doing security all right your airport in
Sydney they're really cool very nice now
I come from a country that doesn't
traditionally have that kind of a thing
going on but sometimes they do and I
always make it a point to like stop and
say who's the manager on and say this
person was great like they did their job
but they didn't make anybody feel
uncomfortable they were smiling and they
were just asking how was your day you
can still be professional and be a human
being and I appreciate that and it
seemed like almost everybody came across
both times I've been to Australia was
always just like hey oh don't worry
about it you just go over here and
nobody was yelling it was great I loved
it and so if somebody were to ask you
know where do you want to where do you
want to stop over where would you like
to go through it makes me go well which
ones which security would be the least
painful for me to go through and the
most pleasant and enjoyable I'm gonna
pick Sydney that's what I choose so this
is where I want to connect through right
that is exactly the same kind of thing
that happens to a manager when they're
trying to figure out who do we want to
give this responsibility to I know it's
kind of a silly thing to correlate but
that we already have so much going on as
Hume
we don't wanna make it harder your
attitude absolutely matters and if you
have a bad one fix that first before
having the expectation that you're going
to be visible because life isn't fair we
would love to be a meritocracy but we're
actually not at all we are trying to go
towards that to where the code you
produce is what differentiates you from
a good or a bad developer but that's not
the reality of the situation we judge
here the human connection even before we
judge their code the day I learned to
accept this fact as hard as I may try
some things are still out of my control
okay I could learn to make coffee
although I'm still an amateur but what I
really need to do was change my attitude
like making coffee maybe placate someone
because look I'm showing them that I
care that they're grumpy in the morning
but if I'm still also grumpy with them
it's still not gonna help the situation
all you've done is introduce caffeine to
the situation which sometimes improves
things but have you ever been that
person who got their fourth cup of
coffee and you're still grumpy yeah the
attitude really does matter so now when
I wake up and I'm really jet-lagged
which happens here a lot and I'm like oh
my gosh I just want to sleep a little
longer I just feel so grateful that I'm
not home and I get to do something
different with my day so I drag myself
out of bed and go how does need a cup of
coffee to feel like a human and I tell
myself that after I get to like my fifth
cup of coffee right but really to feel
human is kind of like you have to make a
choice okay it has to be a choice or
anybody is anybody here a parent having
any kids
yeah lots of kids awesome the next
generation you just have to make a
choice to feed your children even when
you don't feel like make you food okay
you got to make a choice to have a good
attitude when you don't feel like having
a good attitude
and that sounds awful but the funny
thing about the human brain is that if
you do things with your body you can
actually simulate your responses to give
you little shots of dopamine based on
doing something as simple as forcing a
smile force a smile eventually you're
gonna get like a little shot of dopamine
that's like the essence of like fake it
till you make it right like I'm just
gonna pretend to be a bee until I'm
actually happy and it does work usually
it starts with somebody again yeah I'm
I'm having such a good day and you start
laughing at yourself and that laughter
actually does trigger a positive
chemical response and then eventually
you just feel better isn't that cool
I mean I love science it's amazing
computers are amazing but human beings
man it's a whole nother level of Awesome
with the things that we can do with some
applied knowledge and really that's what
you came here to learn today is how to
decode and debug human being because
that's how you're going to become
visible my own experience in business
has taught me that career advancement
depends on a combination of factors
right your skill your attitude your luck
and opportunity while you can control
some of these others will always be
beyond your control skill attitude luck
opportunity you have to have all four of
those to be in that elite group when I
say the elite group I really just mean
the people that come first to mind when
you think of this subject matter or you
think of hey do you know any awesome
people that do micro services right away
you're already thinking all right maybe
you work with them or maybe you know
them online do you know anybody that
does test-driven development who's the
first person that comes to your head why
is that probably a combination of
several of these sorry
telling me I gotta wrap up here all
right to become visible you have to show
others that you see them first listening
is the most impactful thing you can do
to change a career you might not always
like your colleagues but learning to
work with difficult people is essential
for movie now okay
work on your team-building skills and
take advantage of opportunities to lead
to become visible share what you've done
often utilize those social media outlets
to reach outside your company sometimes
it takes being externally recognized for
your internal colleagues to take notice
and to become visible inspire by example
because passion is really contagious so
you got to be that without expecting
anything in return you just got to be
that don't just be the example of what
good work looks like let it like
radiates from you and the attitude that
you approach it with because then people
are gonna want to it's contagious they
want to do it with you reach out first
to share with excitement and invite
people to the table your eyes will be a
very natural one if you do this and it
is almost always this way because if you
want to stand out from the crowd you got
to give people a reason to not forget
you or another way that you could put it
is be so good they can't ignore you but
also know that you're good enough and
don't hide it thank you
[Applause]